that's right after seeing Chuck Norris
on screen for the first time and forever
I thought one thing I'm not shaving for
this video I'm keeping the stubble
hopefully by the end of this video I'm
going to have the source of Chuck
Norris's powers you can't even tell it
in shape can you depressing
The Expendables 2 so doing this video is
going to be simple because the concept
of the Expendables 2 is pretty simple
the concept of the first Expendables
movie was to take all the action stars
of the past and put them all in one
movie now thing as though a couple of
the big actors of the 80's missed out on
that party namely jean-claude van Damme
and Chuck Norris they were supposed to
be in it then they weren't then I guess
I saw the first movie they're like oh
we're down for a sequel if you want to
do that please we need jobs so now we
have the Expendables 2 with more mayhem
and testosterone and explosions and guns
and all the cool things that make the
world go round and make it just a little
more awesome movie wise that is from the
get-go the movie starts out in an action
scene so you're like alright so I know
what I'm in for
50 cals are shredding through guys heads
are exploding you're like it's so it
starts out completely kick-ass and then
it goes you know and they have alright a
little bit of dialogue going on the
action kind of slows down then it picks
back up there's another action saying
the Expendables 2 had a lot less down
time than the first Expendables movie
the first Expendables movie I felt like
there were a lot of scenes where you're
like I shoot something please I built
this one had a lot less downtime they
fixed that still had downtime but any
action movies gonna have downtime
jean-claude Van Damme's the bad guy in
this movie I didn't know that I thought
he was just gonna be part of the crew
okay now Van Dam's and know he's the bad
guy he's the douchebag and he is a great
douchebag dude owns his role in this
movie didn't tell he had a good time
with this movie he's like if Johnny Cage
from Mortal Kombat just had a really bad
childhood and he was raised by Shao Khan
it's good to see him back on screen he
really kicks ass good to see him as a
villain too when Chuck Norris came on
screen I half expected him to be just
like dr. Manhattan you know just
assembling tanks with his mind and
crushing him into balls and slamming him
on the ground
big blue dong just swinging around
you're like that's the Lord with a gun
the deuce awesome he's an icon of pop
culture his acting is every bit as good
as it was in Walker Texas Ranger I mean
that sincerely kick-ass guy though he
could be the piss out of me as I mean
I can't talk about I can you
know he'll end my life with his mind
some of the dialogue in this movie I'm
like that's just terrible I mean it's
cheesy it's ridiculous it's terrible but
the good thing about this movie is it
knows exactly what it is some things you
know they wrote it know like yeah this
is just going to be cheesy the entire
concept of the Expendables is a
Roback to 80s action movies what a movie
knows exactly what it is and doesn't try
to be some modern art masterpiece you
got to give it credit you can't really
be like I'm gonna ding you on the
dialogue there buddy the person who
penned the scripts like I know about the
dialogue you dumb and I love how
they had a bunch of references on their
movies I'm back I'm not going to tell
you a lot of the references but there's
some good references in this movie and
the end of this movie guys the end of
this movie I had dreamed at the end of
this movie I was like what would it be
like if these specific action heroes
were in one action scene and they were
just tearing the out of everything
it happened I saw it willed into reality
but a little cinematic reality which
still isn't real but it was real enough
for me the end of this movie is complete
kick-ass it's what you wanted in the
first Expendables movie might not have
gotten entirely now you have it in the
Expendables 2 the end of this movie
alone made me hype for the third movie
the movie knows what it is it knows it's
an action movie that's a throwback to
80s action movies it knows it's cheesy
and it knows how to show you a good time
is it perfect now not at all did I have
fun with the movie yep I did The
Expendables 2 as a whole is a completely
kick-ass time no alcohol required if
you're looking to watch a movie that's
gonna hold you over until the great
gatsby comes out I wouldn't recommend
this one but if you want a cool kick-ass
movie that fix some of the flaws in the
first Expendables movie still isn't
perfect but is a good time Expendables 2
it's pretty fun right so favorite action
movie of all time
what is it comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more I'll get out of
here a break oh love
you